hey you never know you may be sitting
back at that table again would you ever
no no you don't know thank you so much
i actually really excited for other
people to get to do it too yeah you know
i if to me it felt like tv grad school
was like four years of like tv grad
school now i'm good
okay so let's start with the title of
your audio memoir
bad republican
you said it's kind of like a good
nickname also makes for a great title so
what gives why did you what exactly is a
bad republican in your eyes and why did
you feel like that was appropriate for
an appropriate title it was actually
from a conversation my agent and i have
had like a million times where um i
would be like up for a job and i was
like well do they want me to be the bad
republican on a panel or a show or a
project or whatever they want me to be
the commentator that's like the villain
in a situation and then i sort of felt
like that was my job when i worked at
the view and many different spaces and
then it's also a joke because when i do
things in conservative circles i'm the
bad republican because i'm not the trump
supporter right so it's like it doesn't
matter which sphere i'm in i'm the bad
republican and i just thought it was
like kind of funny and irreverent and
sort of like trying to take ownership of
stereotypes and things and i thought it
was catchy too so and there's some juicy
stuff there is some juicy stuff i mean
we got to get to the juicy stuff some of
the juicy stuff of course is about the
view you do not shy away
about your experience at the view did
you give abc did you give the view a
heads up on specifics in your book no
because i had left the show and i
actually added a chapter because
obviously i would be doing things like
this and people would have questions
about why i left yeah so i actually
added there's only one chapter on the
view in the book and it's the last one
right the departure this has been a
really wild ride the past four years of
my life it's been
honestly the best of times and the worst
of times in all ways on and off this
show yeah and i felt like
i like gossip and i know people wanted
to know and i think it's fair you say
joining the view was a hazing experience
i also say working on the view brings
out the worst in people it does another
comment culture the culture is so messed
up it feels like quicksand all very
strong statements you also say quote
going back to the view whatever
camaraderie we established before was
gone this is in relation to your
maternity leave yeah i talk about the
moment i decided to leave which um was
the moment that i think if you're a view
fan you probably remember was was when
joey told me she didn't miss me okay
somebody asked you treated me so much
when i was on maternity leave you missed
me so much you missed fighting with me
i did not miss you
okay
i just thought like
i just don't think this is well women
should be treated when they come back
from maternity leave and i felt also
like the camaraderie of the show had
dissipated and coveted because of
the satellite the fact that we were
physically apart from each other really
hurt the show i mean there's nothing
anyone could do about it obviously but
it did have an impact have you moved on
from that are you expecting an apology
do you want one and people keep asking
me if you saw any of the women on the
show what would you do first of all i'm
still good friends with sonny um and i
would if i saw any of them i would say
hello and give them a hug joy included
and i wish them really you know i felt
like for so long when i talked about the
hazing period in the show it was more
that the second week i was there there
was a bunch of articles on gossip sites
talking about how nobody liked me on the
show and i was a disappointment and i
was an ice queen and an ice princess and
i was so cold backstage and i had been
there like less than two weeks and i it
was hard for me to understand why people
were basically talking
you know about someone who just got
there so when i say hazing that's what
i'm talking about like the media hazing
and i didn't realize that like this is
the world that i was going to subsist in
now that every time i walked into a
building there could be something when i
leave your relationship with whoopi it
seemingly started so good you referred
to your relationship with her in the
beginning as being maternal she told
your dad that she was basically going to
have your back what was the catalyst
that sparked what was seemingly this
negative dive in y'all's relationship i
don't care that you don't care just hear
what i'm saying
we're gonna go
well
then good megan then you can be how you
always are we'll be able to be how you
always are where did things go wrong
between you and whippy i think again it
was covered and being via satellite i do
i also think that um
trump years were really arduous and
intense for everyone and i think
sometimes i'm the only conservative
person people come into contact with in
media and certainly on the view
and
i just think that there were moments in
time that she doesn't realize how
powerful she is and she's one of the
most powerful american women of all time
one of the most talented actresses one
of the most talented broadcasters she's
a living legend and even small slights
the audience is very savvy they can pick
up on things
but we had a really beautiful ending
what did that ending look like we just
had a lovely conversation when i left
and she sent me some really lovely text
messages and then
um well i you know obviously i don't
want to like reveal too much but
i really wish would be all the best i
will always love her i think she
probably has still has love for me
someplace too hey you never know you may
be sitting back at that table again
would you ever no no you don't know
thank you so much you know
i actually really excited for other
people to get to do it too yeah you know
i if to me it felt like tv grad school
was like four years of like tv grad
school now i'm good regarding your time
at the view you say it was never the
hosts that were the issues it was the
backstage bull
but you do right that the host did play
a part but they weren't the ones that
were saying crap in the media okay and
that i could deal with host drama all
day long to me the thing that started
having a real impact on my
mental and emotional health was the the
const and it became constant like
absolute constant
like leaking from the show wow i mean
i'm telling you this audio memoir is
very eye-opening to say the least i hope
people like it it's not meant to be like
scorched earth maybe it comes off that
way again is a privilege to be on the
view it really is it's one of the most
confident jobs in all of television and
it was truly an honor to do it
it was just
the specific period of time i was on it
it's interesting because i have become
very friendly with elizabeth hasselbeck
and we sort of when i left the show we
traded war stories and she was on during
the bush years and i was on during the
trump years and i do think there's
something about being on that show when
you're a conservative under a
conservative presidency that adds a
different element to it because you are
on the defense which is much harder than
being on the offense politically and
um
yeah i mean but i really i have no
regrets i mean it was a fantastic time
so much of it too like i had a great
time i just
you know i'm one of two hosts that
wasn't fired i quit like so i think that
says something too i think leaving on my
own terms was really important to me and
leaving my way and not being sucked into
um you know the paranoia of not knowing
when when your last show is
um
but i don't i really feel like it was a
liberating experience it was really
tough and hard but i also like so many
people
in america and the world i really got a
pause to reassess what i wanted my life
to look like you said that one of the
most difficult aspects of the book to
write was about your father's passing
and you write about it in
really excruciating detail it was you
know
having experienced the loss of my own
father to cancer
thank you and
being there for his death it is
when you watch your father pass or
anyone pass for that matter it's a very
sacred and intimate moment
why did you want to share this sacred
and intimate moment of your father
passing with your your listeners
because i didn't know what death would
be like and because i described in the
audible book that i became obsessed with
it i became obsessed with the last
moments of of anyone's life and what the
process of dying is like and i'm a
sharer and i'm very open and my dad was
very open with his cancer and with his
process
into going on to the next life and i
think he would have been entertained and
[Music]
appreciated that i was trying to share
my experience with cancer and my
experience with his death and
i sort of wanted to give context to why
if people thought that i was so
emotionally charged
because i was because i had gone through
so much and then i had to go not
straight back on tv because i took
bereavement leave but pretty soon back
on television and it's not like you know
you know i lost to someone who was a you
know a person people didn't know
people everyone knows who my dad was so
um i don't know i'm also just to share
her and i felt like again i had this
incredible opportunity with audible to
tell stories and i feel like people
maybe i'm wrong but i do feel like
people want to know the truth and want
to know what really happened
you